ah face it tiger
Marvel has never really figured out how
to make this work
[Music]
so something happened a couple weeks ago
that
just got my brains spinning a little bit
and I've got stuff to talk out and I get
to actually talk a bit just straight up
about comic books which I don't get to
talk about that much uh partially
because my attempted relaunch of 90s
comic read trial didn't take off if you
want to try and have that uh give that a
late life and Resurgence there's that
video why not but in any case I I enjoy
Comics I don't read them currently uh
right now but I have historically
enjoyed comics and Spider-Man
is one of my favorites Spider-Man 29
specifically is my favorite hero but
Spider-Man in general I love
there were three main things that I was
really into back in the 90s when I was
mostly buying comic books Spider-Man
X-Men and spawn which I will argue the
early parts of spot hold up a lot better
than people think but regardless
Spider-Man was kind of the one that has
the my love of that character is
lingered
X-Men
I've kind of gone up and down on X-Men
can be great
I kind of fell out of love with it even
during the 90s because it was a
convoluted mess spawn I just kind of
grew out of
Spider-Man
's still great
so what happened in the comics well
we're going to be doing a lot of back
history here but
um the immediate thing that got me
kicked off thinking about all this was
that there was an issue where
Peter Peter Parker Spider-Man
said to Black Cat AKA Felicia that
um
he no longer has a love for Mary Jane
now
Mary Jane okay Mary Jane was by far the
longest running
um romantic interest for Spider-Man she
was not the only she was not the first
I'll touch on some of that in a little
bit but she was by far the longest
running
and they were married for a long time
and until there was a storyline called
one more day
that did something stupid and pointless
which was to dissolve their marriage and
I don't mean like they got a divorce
I mean there was literally a deal with
the devil that made it so their marriage
had never happened
I'm not gonna Deep dive into that
because it's it's really stupid
but
after that the established continuity
was still that they did care about each
other that they had dated that most of
the major events that they'd experienced
as a couple did still happen in one way
or another they just were never married
which kind of emphasizes the
pointlessness of it but basically that
has to do with the fact of how far
reaching and undoing of history that
would have been and how many stories it
would have just been like okay so did
any of that happen now to avoid that
massive upheaval of a retcon they made
it very narrowly targeted which just
made it weird even weirder than it
already was but that was a while back
that was over a decade ago
so
why am I irritated by this now
because it just emphasizes that Marvel
doesn't know what the hell to do with
Mary Jane
and hasn't for a very long time part of
that has to do with the origins of how
the two ended up as a married couple in
the first place before we even get there
let's go back a bit because
as I said MJ was not Peter's first love
his first love was Liz
there was also Betty there was Gwen
Stacy who was quite famously known
easily the second best known of his love
interests I I I'm gonna say something
slightly controversial Gwen Stacy
in the comics is really only interesting
for the fact that she died
she's not a particularly interesting
dynamic character she's not awful she's
not bad
but I think if they had just broken up
if they had just parted ways and she
hadn't died
I don't think there'd be nearly as much
interest in her quick point of clarity
when I say that Gwen Stacy was only
really interesting for the fact that she
died I'm talking about original flavor
Gwen Stacy I am well aware we've gotten
some very interesting alternate takes on
her since then but to come back to what
I just said a minute ago yeah I don't
think we would have gotten any of those
if the original hadn't died so yeah I'm
gonna still stand by that point even
though I'm clarifying it so yeah Gwen's
only interesting because she died
I feel the same way about Jason Todd hey
why don't I piss off some DC fans while
I'm at while I'm at it but like there
are some characters that the fact that
they that they died elevates the
interest in them where there wasn't
really much there otherwise hell I'll
come off Comics same thing about adric
the Doctor Who companion who died during
the classic era spoilers for 40 year old
material but
you know character's not interesting oh
but he died and that very rarely
happened at the time that that occurred
oh cool oh well that's interesting the
character's still not that's kind of how
I feel about Gwen now Mary Jane as I
said was a long-running love interest
for Peter actually there was even a
little bit of a sort of a love triangle
thing with Gwen and with MJ and with
beer this like goes back well before my
time so I only kind of know the deals of
that but I do know
why Mary Jane and Peter got married and
it kind of initially plants the seeds
for why Marvel Comics hasn't always
known what to do with her and in fact
seems to resent her presence
which is that
back in the I think it was the I think
it was the 80s by then but at the time
that it happened
Stan Lee wasn't writing Spider-Man he
hadn't for a while
but he was still writing the comic strip
because really date myself now back when
newspapers were a bigger deal and when
comics in newspapers not comic books
comic strips in newspapers were a bigger
deal there was a Spider-Man newspaper
comic strip and Stan Lee was writing
that
and he decided that he was going to have
MJ and Peter get married
and in order to keep in parity with each
other that meant the comics very hastily
got the two hitched but there's more
than enough word that behind the scenes
the folks working at Spider-Man were
kind of resentful that they had to do
that they had wanted Peter to get
married which brings me to one of the
first reasons why
Mary Jane was often treated like a
hindrance and a burden
which is that
historically
and oftentimes presently
comic book writers
seem to loathe the idea of a stable
relationship
they just don't like to do it
these relationships pretty much never
last with anybody
because there's more drama in a breakup
in a death in something that isn't
stability I mean what are the stable
relationships in comics Superman and
Lois
that's basically because of Precedence
because they were basically the original
couple they are iconic as a couple you
kind of can't break them up
Comics have still tried a couple of
times
pairing Superman with Wonder Woman was
one of the many very stupid things from
The New 52 but anyways so Superman and
Lois okay
Reed Richards and Sue storm
okay
I mean
to call that a stable relationship is a
it's gone up and down but they haven't
least stayed together for a while there
was Ralph and Sue dibny in DC but um
we're not going to talk about identity
crisis here because that story can burn
and never be discussed again that would
be wonderful
I deeply love that story anyways sorry
DC tangent again but like who else is
there
Batman doesn't have an iconic love
interest closest is Catwoman but they
won't commit to that
I think the only recent instance of a
pairing that that is sticking to any
degree is Harley Quinn and Poison Ivy
but that's a rarity and like that is
also a weird and wonky one for a
multitude of Reason starting with the
fact that they're both anti-heroes so
they both kind of get to bend the normal
rules in the first place but pretty much
everybody else
their love interests leave them die turn
evil that's a big one
because that's an easy way to get more
drama
or another thing that a lot of the
Spider-Man writers seem to want was to
capture this idea of The Swinging single
Spider-Man
which
this is where we kind of get into the
issue of long-running formats like comic
book superheroes where eventually if it
goes on for long enough
sooner or later you're going to have the
people writing it be the people who grew
up as fans of the earlier iterations now
that can both be a benefit and a
detriment it can mean that you have
someone who already has a working
knowledge of the history of this
character and the uh you know what the
iconography is and they're just going to
honor the character better that's your
good situation but what can happen very
frequently is you get
um you get writers
they don't want to write the character
as they are now they want to write the
character as they remember reading them
and so that contributes to this idea of
well Spider-Man should be single
but they they got married and Marvel as
resentful as they seem to be about the
fact that the two of them were married
didn't didn't seem to wanted them to get
a divorce either
I don't know why they couldn't just do
that well I suppose because they'd have
to break the relationship in some way
and how do you do that without damaging
the characters Marvel Marvel learned
that the hard way with Hank Pym because
Hank Pym granted it was under the
influence of Ultron but he hit his wife
Ant-Man hit the wasp
and that character has never recovered
in the eyes of fans ever
and that's the risk if you try and do a
breakup for anything that equates to a
real world reason why people break up
now well not any reason but a dramatic
reason because again there has to be
drama because
it is fully possible to break up without
a big blow up or fight or anything that
people just grow apart and they go this
isn't working anymore
but that's not dramatic so that's never
considered as an option so since they
never seem to be willing to do a divorce
they instead did the deal with the devil
technically it's Mephisto Mephisto is
the devil it's a deal with the devil why
Mephisto cares that their marriage is
dissolved
is weird and vague and doesn't make a
lot of sense as I said the fact that it
doesn't undo their relationship just
the fact that vows were exchanged makes
it at most symbolic and borderline
meaningless
the fact that Peter did this to save
Aunt May a woman who is not only
so freaking old but even setting that
aside and you know taking into
consideration into consideration his
commitment to where how much he loves
her how much he's depended on her like
she wouldn't want this she
would not ever want you to do this
but that's the motivation they came up
with
it
it was real dumb
but because of the Fallout in the
aftermath of that has been so weird and
nebulous and like they still have to
acknowledge the fact that MJ and Peter
have been together or at some points
even were still together but just
weren't married and then a couple years
ago they gave Mary Jane a new love
interest guy named Paul
um who so far as I know has not turned
out to be evil yet I expect he will
eventually but uh so far that hasn't
happened and that's kind of the impetus
for what happened recently was Peter
talking to uh Felicia Hardy black cat
another love interest that he has had
off and on you know telling her
I do love her but it's as a sister I've
moved on
the only reason to do that seems to be
because
a lot of fans still think MJ and Peter
should be together
it probably doesn't help that this is
reinforced somewhat by the movies
because Mary Jane while not the only
love interest that has been shown in the
movies has been the main one
she was the love interest in Sam Remy's
uh Spider-Man movies she was the love
interest in uh the Tom Holland I mean
different versions of this but MJ it's
it's Mary Jane in some way shape or form
wasn't in The Amazing Spider-Man but
that's also the franchise that only got
two entries and they did Gwen Stacy the
second most famous so there you go and
then spin-off media like video games and
what have you they tend to favor MJ
because it's the one most readers no
most fans know it's the one most fans
love
so I'd be willing to bet that the entire
idea of pairing MJ with Paul was to be
like here stop asking us to put Peter
and MJ back together she's got somebody
it probably didn't take
and so they just go well Peter isn't
even in love with her anymore let us put
him with black cat now which
aside from just feeling like okay y also
feels very much like trying to recreate
the Batman and Catwoman dynamic
which they've always kind of felt like
but now especially given that Catwoman
is the closest to an iconic love
interest that Batman has ever had
although also can I just tangent on this
real quick
because I'm going to use this to
illustrate aside from the fact that the
mechanism for it was very stupid a big
part of why I hate hate absolutely
loathe that Marvel dissolved Peter's
marriage and it's because in a little
parallel that I get to draw in Batman
under Tom King there was this big build
up to an issue that was going to feature
the marriage of Batman and Catwoman
and a lot of people thought they're not
gonna actually do that not because
people thought it was a bad idea but
because like they're never gonna marry
Batman they're not going to do it why
are you teasing us like oh we're gonna
get the mayor like we know you're not
and in an effort to keep the marketing
and the hype going Tom King who had
written this gave interviews and he
specifically very much from his head no
we're definitely doing this and he said
something that I agree with I agree with
fully which is that
heroes in stable relationships is a very
unexplored area of these kinds of
characters there's so much that could be
done so many news stories that could be
told things that other Heroes aren't
doing if we allow this to happen and
he's right
but he was also lying because Catwoman
leaves him at the altar and they don't
get married minor Corrections because I
misremembered this slightly Tom King was
a little more careful with his wording
than I remembered he didn't actually
insist that the wedding was definitely
gonna happen but he did go off on a
whole thing about how there's this
assumption that Heroes can't be happy
but actually we should explore that and
that is very much something I agree with
and I still consider that to be a lie
because it is painting an image of a
very specific future that he was never
ever planning on doing especially
considering that the whole nonsense of
if Batman is happy he won't be effective
at being Batman is part of the reason
Catwoman leaves him that was so
infuriating for me to hear a Creator say
something that I'm like yes that's true
but he said it as a lie to cover a
surprise that everyone had already
guessed
because as I said
stable relationships are super uncommon
and even a lot of the ones that we've
had like I can look again at Reed
Richards Sue storm they're both super
powered
the ones where one of them doesn't have
powers
generally haven't been allowed to last
Superman and Lois again but other than
that
not a lot
you could do something different you can
explore different stories
you can talk about home life you can
talk about support for someone in a
difficult job you can do stories where
you don't even necessarily have to turn
the spouse into any kind of Damsel in
Distress but you can explore adult
relationships
which these things almost never do
because they want their characters to be
dating they want them in teenage
relationships especially characters like
Spider-Man who as I said a lot of the
writers remember as a teenager
here's one of the weird things about
Spider-Man
for a long time
the Marvel timeline moved forward in
real time
Peter started out in high school he went
to college he graduated he started
getting full-time work he was aging
and that was true of the Marvel universe
as a whole
now eventually they adopted what's been
noted as their rolling timeline where
everybody kind of stops moving forward
and we just kind of fudge time from
there on out but for a while
he was Aging in more or less real time
he was not a teenager for very long
and yet that's the version that gets
adapted
into most uh cartoons that's the version
that got adapted to all three movie
series he at least started out as a
teenager in all three of them and while
I do like the new ones and I like Tom
Holland at Spider-Man when we first
found out he was cast I was really
ticked off because I am sick
of a teenage Spider-Man do you know how
many decades worth of material good
material good stories not only about the
fact that Peter Parker is married he was
a teacher for a while
that was good interesting stuff but no
keep resetting put him back to how he
was originally re-establish his iconic
statements and this is the most bitter
sarcasm air quotes I'm ever gonna put
around anything and again this is not
something that only impacts Spider-Man
I'll take a look at Jeff John's
who is I think still
uh one of the heads at DC the comics end
of it at least
I don't know I haven't checked lately
but
Jeff Johns who is a good writer
and does have some very good ideas
part of the new 52 initiative and even
before that
was this notion of bringing characters
back to their quote unquote
iconic
status
and the best exampler of this is uh the
Flash
Barry Allen's flash had been dead since
crisis on infinite Earths
so for a long time the entire
post-crisis continuity The Flash was
Wally West but when Jeff John's got a
chance to write the Flash
he didn't want to write Wally
wasn't who he grew up with so he brought
back Barry
and for a long time
Wally didn't exist
and then he had things like the new 52
and suddenly Barbara Gordon iconically
Batgirl
but also an important piece of
disability representation something that
Comics sorely lack after she suffered an
injury in a very overrated story called
The Killing Joke and she had to make use
of a wheelchair
suddenly she's out of the chair again
all of the years where she was Oracle
she was a hacker she was an information
broker she was something interesting and
unique as opposed to just another member
of the bat family in Tights no we're
putting her back to her iconic
status
this is in many ways part of the
inherent problem with any
um Story character franchise that goes
on this long
whether they do a full proper reboot or
not
eventually somebody be it an editorial
mandate be it a corporate order or be it
the writers who just want to write the
version they grew up reading somebody's
going to want to roll things back and
set them back how they were before
and again like sometimes it's a creative
Choice from a writer sometimes it's a
cynical Choice from higher ups who are
saying hey the book sold better when
this was the case make that the case
again but regardless
this is an inherent Hazard a very long
form storytelling
that eventually things just get rolled
back and reset
and while I understand why it happens
it is one of the things that I think
really does put a lot of people off
comics
and why it's a lot easier to get into
the movies
because here's this version of this
character you stick with us through
three movies and some spin-offs cool
awesome you're probably not gonna reset
that character over the course of that
I mean you might who knows but
that's that's a commitment I can make
but to commit to years and years of
reading a comic
and know in the back of my head
eventually whatever it is that I like is
going to be abandoned
if not completely reversed undone and
retconned
why why would I get invested
in a medium that does that
and I say that as someone who does like
comic books
but there are some serious hazards
with how long running these things are
and to be clear this is partially a fan
problem because Comics fans are
notoriously
very hard to please and that's not even
a new thing like this has been a case
for decades about as long as I've been
alive comic book fans have been very
hard to please and very vocal when they
aren't
and I get that they we
are also part of the problem
because some of us want things to move
forward involved some of us want things
to go back the way that they were
and you can't please both of those but
to make enough money to have to be worth
it you have to try and please both and
you just end up with a mess you end up
with a situation where okay we're gonna
try and move forward because we're gonna
we're gonna push forward with Peter and
Felicia but you have the fans going but
MJ's still around why isn't he with MJ
well MJ's with another guy no but why
can't you get because he doesn't even
love her anymore okay let us now do
something else
is that the actual thought process any
of the people involved in this recent
decision had I don't know but it
certainly feels like that sometimes and
I'm not unsympathetic to that how
frustrating that must be
but it also makes for frustrating
reading engagement again especially
given the long-running nonsense
with
the fact that Comics just
won't let characters be adults
and not in The Superficial oh we're so
adult we're gonna kill a bunch of
characters and have everybody with
massive guns and all these pouches with
ammo like no that's not adult that's
juvenile
I mean adult mature relationships
interactions
foundations
in adult
Concepts like maintaining a marriage
they just don't
they don't they never do and when they
do they they roll back on it eventually
so this was this was a very unfocused
thing because
ultimately there's only so much I have
to say about what they're doing with
Spider-Man but boy does it connect to a
whole bunch of other stuff that drives
me absolutely up the wall about the
comics industry
and it's a shame
but it's also what got us to the
situation we're in where
the comics are much better as a test bed
and a character creation kitchen for
things to be adapted to other mediums
trying to actually get into Comics
themselves
now I get it I get I I get why they
don't succeed
because you think with how popular comic
book movies are oh the comics must be
selling well now too no because the
comics put people off
the movies don't the movies simplify
well they do up to a point Marvel or
over a decade of Marvel Now Marvel is
starting to the movies are starting to
Veer into the territory of having gone
on too long
and while thankfully we haven't got
massive robots and rollbacks and resets
and we've managed to avoid that
it is starting to feel like
the universe as a whole just
is constantly recycling through similar
threats movie to movie and
that can still be fun but after a while
the impact is okay
so um yeah I just needed to rant that
out for a while
because boy the comics
these writers need to get over some of
their Hang-Ups
about writing married people about
writing stable relationships
just let people be together
have them work
occasionally
just try it
you might like it
because you know what
speaking of someone who got into
Spider-Man in the 90s
I really liked MJ and Peter
as a married couple
because for all the nonsense that went
on during that point
that was probably one of their most
stable stretches as a couple
because down the line you'd get stuff
about attempting to have a kid
miscarriages and a whole bunch of other
stuff
but during the time when I was reading
there was a lot of chaos going on I came
in towards the start of the clone saga
you know coming off the back of uh
things like uh Maximum Carnage
you know it was great
foreign having this Central stable Force
being
Peter and MJ
that all the other stuff going on
Peter's parents coming back to them
turning out to be robot duplicates
all of that nonsense felt more
manageable because there was the
stabilizing force of the two of them
together I knew reading that at the end
of Any Given insane Adventure Peter got
to go home there she was and they were
good for each other
and I wouldn't have been able to
articulate
why that was important when I was 12
. but I can now
and it has value
anyway what are your thoughts on any of
the nonsense I've gone off about
whatever they are drop something down
the comments let's talk about it patreon
pays the bills and enables me to do this
as my living even if you can't support
me that way the like share subscribe
also help me out but don't worry too
much about it because what I really want
you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
this video wouldn't have been possible
without my supporters over on patreon
and I would especially like to thank
Robin Moore Zubin love fola Tarak the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B
ulurik Bogdan Melinda Walters imudelki
theota Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
for Nabi lacks the poodle Robin Powell
Tracy scrabot angry Casper Tim price
Adam RDL Taylor David Hall General
contact unit Problem Child Shayla
gourlay and Rosalind Bennett
thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]